Nvidia shield tablet may well be an
early glimpse at the future of gaming
the one device to rule them all idea
that lets you surf and email and work
and game from a tablet on the go and
then kick back with a controller and
playing your big-screen TV when you're
at home it's absolutely a neat concept
but I'm not so sure the tech is quite
there just yet to pull it off that tech
is based on NVIDIA Tegra k1
system-on-a-chip which uses a Kepler
based GPU with 192 cuda cores paired
with a quad-core arm cortex a15 2
gigabytes of RAM and a sharp 190 200 by
1200 pixel inch display it's an
impressive setup which makes for
impressive performance across the board
shield tablet zips through pretty much
anything you throw at it which makes
navigating through the largely stock
version of Android 4.4.3 it ships with
and absolute joy some might be
disappointed not to see a higher dpi
display here such as that of the iPad
Mini that shield tablets display is
clear bright and has great viewing
angles it's also better for running
games the more taxing of which will
stress the GPU at 1080p nvm anything
higher that display also makes a lot
more sense when you see the price tag at
just $299 or 229 pounds for the 16
gigabyte Wi-Fi version or $399 or 299
pounds for a 32 gigabyte version with 4G
the shield tablet is certainly in the
ballpark of the lights of the Nexus 7
and I'd more than happily pay the extra
few pounds for the extra power and
features on offer for starters there's
the wonderful inclusion of a microSD
slot for up to 128 gigabytes of storage
expansion which will prove particularly
useful if you got a large game and media
collection the stereo speakers to either
side of the screen are plenty loud
there's an actual mini HDMI slot for
video out which saves faffing with micro
USB adapters
you're banned 802 11 n Wi-Fi and there's
a stylus because hey styluses yay
battery life is good if not stunning
Nvidia claims ten hours of video
playback and I could certainly squeeze
out a day's worth of heavy use before
having to reach for a charger playing
games does zap the battery fast though
so if you're planning on playing lots of
games you will need to keep the charge
as a hand there are also 5 megapixel
cameras on the front and back of the
device the rear camera doesn't take the
best pictures for the front-facing
camera makes for surprisingly good
selfie cam the stills and video indeed
even if you never use any of the shield
tablets gaming specific features you're
getting a great tablet for the money it
feels solidly built with a reassuring
390 gram weight that's not too heavy for
one-handed use and a reasonable
thickness of 9.2 millimeters and while
there's no accounting for taste
I'd argue that it looks pretty good too
if you do use the gaming features you'll
need to fork out for the shield
controller for an extra fifty nine
dollars for 49 pounds and the kickstand
case spoon of the 39 bucks there are no
discounted bundles at launch which is a
missed opportunity for the full gaming
setup you're looking at almost an extra
$100 on top of the tablet price and for
that the shield controller is a bit of
an ugly duckling and is on the large
side so those with smaller hands might
find it a little uncomfortable the d-pad
and shoulder buttons well they're a tad
mushy too that said it does work as
advertised although I found it all too
easy to accidentally activate the touch
sensitive Android buttons while playing
a game the controller comes into its own
when you plug the tablet into a TV via
HDMI and it offers to start in console
mode and it brings up a simple to the
point interface that lets you load up
apps and games purchase them on the
native games front there on a whole
at launch so far there are just 11 Tegra
k1 optimized games including half-life 2
the tablet also comes with a free copy
of trine 2 which is a nice touch I tried
both half-life 2 and trying to and found
both games look great but didn't run
without issue half-life 2 in particular
had lots of noticeable framerate issues
during busiest scenes and while it
didn't ever get to the point where the
game was unplayable who was
disappointing to see from a Tegra k1
device twitch streaming is native to the
shield tablet and is easily activated at
any point by holding down the back
button on the controller for the most
part it works well complete with picture
in picture and audio from the built-in
mic but the framerate in native android
games takes a hit when the feature is
activated perhaps an update or two will
fix this in the future but for now
graphics intensive games and twitch
streaming aren't the best of friends
fortunately twitch streaming and game
stream do work well together game stream
lets you stream games from your PC to
your tablet wirelessly and shrink aims
do look impressive provided that you've
got a good clear wireless signal while
there's no mistaking them from native
games thanks to a few lights video
compression artifacts and look and play
great however if you've got a poor Wi-Fi
connection then the quality and
responsiveness of stream games takes a
hit I like to think of the shield tablet
this way if you buy one you're getting a
great powerful Android tablet with an
ear stock version of the OS with some
cool gaming features thrown in for a
great price
I wouldn't necessarily get a shield
tablet for its gaming features alone
though indeed if you're buying it solely
for the gaming features you might be a
little disappointed but if you're
interested in what the future of gaming
might look like shield tablet is perhaps
the best glimpse we've had at it so far
Oh